so good to see all of you uh i watched
the first 38 minutes of the movie mind
blown it is absolutely incredible
everyone's dissecting the trailers and
garfield's being bombarded on his press
tour so here's my question how does this
film live up to the multiverse height
tom
i mean in so many ways in so many ways
we've you've been saying a lot that the
one word to describe this film is
satisfying um you know it's fulfilling
fans have got so many high expectations
for what they think this film is going
to be you know
i really hope that they're as as
thrilled as we are with the film yeah
you know when you open something as as
daunting and as massive as the
multiverse it gives you an endless
amount of possibilities what we can
create and you know we really did leave
no stone unturned um and i think this
film won't disappoint
yeah and and you know when you right off
the top the adventure starts right
you're swinging around mj and from
bridges to here and there it's an
indication how you guys have grown
within this franchise what has it meant
for you to be on this adventure together
this stunts defined project together we
love scenes on bridges we do yeah
yeah yeah everything
important happens everything it does
actually
there's an older bridge london bridge
the charles bridge
the manhattan
is it the mana ambridge or the 47 bridge
what's that one called it might be i
think you guys might have been on the
brooklyn bridge no it's the one where
that that uh that that uh the
the um
we're on a tangent sorry i know you're
on a bridge like more monorail thing
that goes over the river it's like a big
red box i know what you're talking about
yeah yeah definitely the camping of the
nation right now
for both of you right like this has been
a pretty amazing project
oh that's been incredible and we get to
share it with each other which is even
more special you know like i think we
have memories and you know experiences
that no one else has been able to have
except for us three i mean i've had the
literal view of
your spider-man head and jacob behind
you
you know how we swing yeah that's that's
not a view that a lot of people have
been able to do
it is special and jacob you know the
fact that tom just said when you open up
the multiverse there's so much going on
uh super villains which is your favorite
which is my favorite i i really can't
speak on who's my favorite because they
were all pretty amazing yeah i think
that i think they all bring their own
sort of special unique
uh take and the fact that you were able
to have them all back on and really have
them all kind of get back into those
parts was really really really
satisfying as a fan so
i mean to say there's a favorite that'd
be really rude pick one come on jacob
pick one
i mean oh my goodness i really can't i
really can't say but i think they're all
pretty pretty lit
and going into the storyline we see this
array you know doctor strange is trying
to do the spell peter parker is talking
too much he just wants to go back before
mystery and blab that all the identity
and all of that do you think peter
parker was it was right for him to ask
for the spell or do you think he should
have dealt with what was going on people
knowing i think we i think we all kind
of agree that he should have just dealt
with it yeah
yeah
he probably should have just proved his
innocence yeah i think would have been
way easier to prove it than to like try
to go and fix this fix it with a smile
yeah i think that should have really
been
his first
thing but he's a teenager he overreacts
he doesn't know how to deal with his
problems yet oh peter
peter
[Music]
you know what mate just
take a minute
something a little more
yeah you'll be fine and cindy i just
want to say as a mother of two daughters
i'm so proud of you you are killing it
and you are such an inspiration your
your light is so bright right now and we
just absolutely love you and thanks for
the inspiration really really appreciate
everything you appreciate that so much
and what about the world you guys are
great too but zendaya is like
my girlfriend
you are killing me right now you are
kidding me right now shining bright like
a diamond
you